hello Lisa Lisa Ann is here we were just
talking about how yeah we're on yes
we're just talking about how precious
what are two phones in your pockets what
do you use what do you use it for all
right yeah you do need you need is one a
work phone and one a personal phone nope
I don't use the number on the second
phone at all it's just for gallivanting
it's just for who has the number on the
second phone no wherever your dating has
to have it no one come on it's a phone
setting is off permanently on do not
disturb
I don't want it for a phone for a camera
right Dora you know everything that I
like that doesn't have people
interrupting me and asking me weird
things could you tweet this for me you
know like stop one let's get a tweet
everything I get about a hundred
requests today from people like oh can
you treat this for me like okay how many
followers yet um 1.3 million okay so
yeah they want to get it out but I also
have about a million blocked
I love blocking people and I've really
upped my blocking game Wow
there is it's adrenaline pinching you
like it I love it block them for a while
it was a numbers game so I would just
hit mute right because you still get the
numbers right you still want your
follower account to be at a certain
point but now now I'm just this
different person where I'm not as greedy
and and I like my quota is at least ten
a day don't block the day it normally
it's Instagram because they really get
haywire and the commentary and very
little on Instagram it's mostly
Twitter's it's just the opposite sorry
okay most my hatred comes on well yeah
because you're black and view black
people on Twitter already yeah so you
don't see them so now they start
sprinkling out towards Instagram now
we've talked about this before do you
have a time of the day where you'll wake
up in the morning and go like okay let's
say I wake up at 8 o'clock from 8:15 to
8 24 I even venture into the world of
social media at least one hour oh that's
good
yeah get your brain going in a positive
spin you know space right why do you
want to look at that just verbal vomit
but do you have do you have do you have
a cut-off point to when you're like okay
I do spend because you say you're like
you're blocking people
so is it ten minutes five minutes thirty
seconds a day that you spend blocking
and then you're done or is it just as it
as it comes it's kind of as it comes but
I'll do it for about a twenty minute
span I've been really into time
management lately so I set my timer on
my phone when I'm gonna troll through
comments on say Instagram because it's
kind of time consuming so I'll take that
twenty minutes when the alarm goes off
it's like okay I guess these people are
saved because I went off and I'm not
walking anymore
I'll tell you you asked what it's mostly
about now that I've come back I'm 50
pounds lighter than I was when I was in
the business in 2014 congratulations and
it's just been a natural it's not been a
getting on the scale first of all I'd
made the full switch to going vegan and
I feel amazing
it's more sleeping more living in a
better routine when you lose weight
being a vegan because Patrice went vegan
he put weight on because he was eating
like all kinds of like breads and like
pastas it was not doing carbs the breads
are pasta even so a lot of like soups
salads beans I bake vegetables I'll do
root vegetables and broiled it like I'm
eating more calories than I really ever
ate I'm just eating the right calories
really nutrient-dense foods so I'm
getting a lot of hate about being
thinner now understand something you
will never insult a woman by telling her
she's too thin there's not a woman in
the world that will tell me she's
insulted so when you get the trolls
they're like oh you used to be hot but
now you're skinny you're like yeah when
they say so what I realized is I'm
actually doing a public service right so
they can still look at all of my old
content while era where I was heavier
right and they can follow an impostor
who's just all putting up old photos of
me as well I'm keeping them in the
mindset they want to stay in while I can
go about my day but that's what you've
always been about your porn career is
that the beauty of it is you didn't
offer everybody already it's right but I
feel healthier and I think it's it's
made me also think about the images that
we've set for what the standard is for
what's sexy for a woman and I think
we've gotten really into this like huge
you know but thing and I work out in
Encino and there's all these women that
have the fake butt and in in regular
daylight like it it reminds me of the
old
cheers that had boobs bigger than their
head it's weird-looking to see this tiny
girl with this massive but I don't like
a fake ass yeah I guess it's becoming
more and more popular they fake-ass
chica you could feel them too you can
you can see them as well sorry no it's
just raining I really wanted snow guys
it's supposed to it's supposed to start
selling so uh
yeah okay uh I was just at a strip club
in LA and there wasn't one girl with a
real ass the whole place wow that thing
now but are there less breast implants
now that used to be like you couldn't
get into the business without a boob job
right it was like your it was like your
a resume here right you have a boob job
liquid good or bad we're taking it right
they could be over here doesn't matter
did you get an award you have to get
this move job now it's a button I wonder
what its gonna look like in about ten
years
what are these butts aged have they age
I don't know you know what they probably
don't the price just kind of stay where
they are they probably don't drop or
anything so the rest of woman drops and
they're just these putting things they
probably just kind of hang out there no
wait this is exciting ten years now we
can meet and talk about this topic yeah
because they might go lower and start to
flap over the thigh they might get
dimple II like you don't know what's
gonna do you have them by slowly if you
have them taken out like if you have
those Assam plants but your skin just
droop or your skin kind of go back to
what it was well it would be kind of
like when I got my boobs taken out went
smaller of course they have to remove
skin and surgically you know make
everything nice again what did you go
from what to what I went from a 36
double D to now I am a 32 Triple D so
don't be afraid of the 32 be happy about
the triple D's I tell people very
disturbing tool and also this part of my
body looks a good 22 years old because I
drew my nipples how I wanted them I did
everything perfectly and I gave this to
my doctor and I'm like this is what I
want them to look like so that's what he
did so I'm getting a lot of comments on
the internet like what you do in your
nipples like I just freshen them up
woman what do you can make them smaller
you can I did Irish ape them completely
and they just looked so young impression
perk you like him perk you and smaller I
tend to like them are like a [ __ ] a
bit of a big disaster like I like
larger and that does happen to women as
mine we're a big disaster and I was just
like you know I'm done looking at that
let's freshen this up that's so
empowering and women to be like I can
have the nipples that I want to have
custom designing me right since it's
some girls women get the thing done
whether their nipples they lose
sensitivity when they go in through that
area and I didn't go in through that
area but yes you now it was totally
different but I didn't lose any
sensitivity so the the blocking is about
that
of course the boobs and the butt in the
wait so I'm just like I'm just trying to
save people from looking at something
they don't like yeah well they say to
you that well you look like got you
blocked you were so much better before
you need to eat something you look
horrible thin things like that I'm like
okay I'm not gonna take it personally I
don't give who you are I don't care
about you but it is pure pleasure so how
has the reaction because you got a
non-porn body after you left yeah never
thought I would do porn again right I
don't know where you come back how long
were you out um over three years okay
and then and for a year I planned my
comeback I wrote up in the journal for
12 months which I'm gonna put in my next
book about my thoughts do you want to do
this then I shot my first scene and told
nobody and then held on to it for a
couple of weeks before I even knew what
I was gonna do with it just to see do I
feel different since I shot this scene
is that what everybody says am i a
different person no I feel is saying
exactly the same wait now you're much
more in control than before right I own
all of my content I'm producing
directing so it's all up to me what
happens from picking the location to
picking the music that I'm using for the
scene laying on my boxart
evil angel is distributing for me but
they're really allowing me to have full
control over everything I want to do and
you're picking your own co-stars no yeah
it's so fun your first scene back what
what type of setting was it a beautiful
home in Beverly Hills a really nice
bathroom area I knew I wanted to release
on Valentine's Day so we made it a scene
almost like a husband and wife going out
for dinner and the husband comes in to
zip up the woman's dress which was me
and then it just got intimate right
there because it was a gorgeous bathroom
with this textured walls that I really
like I'm scouting locations and I'm
taking pictures and I'm like
he's bald he would look really good in
this bathroom with all of this wall
texture I'm getting really into the
aesthetics visually because it's
something that I think we're missing in
porn right now so you didn't feel at all
like after you shot that first scene
there was no because like you can build
it up when you leave something like porn
you build it up in your own head like
okay I'm done with it I'm not gonna be
one of those people I'm over I'm over
and then three years later you're back
there was no sort of like you felt like
oh my pride is shot because I went
around saying I'm not gonna do this
anymore and now I'm doing it again I
felt like why did I allow the world to
convince me that I was going to be a
better person when I left the industry
cuz I'm the same person that I was then
and also why is no one that's succeeding
staying around and being an influencer
to the young talent in the business
right so it's tenfold now because I'm
able to reach out and weekly I'm putting
time aside each week to teach girls how
to use different software for social
media to help them with their banking to
introduce them to people so they just
are doing things properly because really
these girls and guys are making an
incredible amount of money still to this
day they still get paid good I just
heard that the money went down like
since all these cams and all sites yeah
it just seems like it's harder it's
harder to find stars doctor there's so
many people you could just the money is
there it does take a little bit more
hustle now than it used to but that's
just like anything else now you got to
be releasing something just like us here
it's serious we not only do our shows
but then they're cut in there on demand
there's all these different ways you can
go about accessing the content you just
have to be ready to provide all those
different outlets for your people and
the money is still there now are you
sitting there like watching these tube
sites to make sure nobody's bootlegging
your stuff is that evil angels evil
angel works on that for me which is
great I do understand that people are
gonna do it and it's one of those things
I don't want to put too much effort to
you know what I mean it's it's stopping
yeah well I will stop when I can but I
don't want to troll like there's some
producers that like troll for like four
or five hours a day that's all they do
I'm like okay that's a bit obsessive
sure you have to understand just like
with music stuff's gonna get taken it
happens you just got to move on and make
new stuff right so it does happen yeah
and what do you think I mean being
high-profile what do you think we're
talking about storming Daniels this is
so exciting
you
who didn't stop watching last night I
needed to go to bed to come here but
Lanie and I just got in I knew she was
still on her way back i text her I'm
like update stormy is suing Trump I'm
watching while I'm reading news
listening to other news on my iPad I
have every bit of information just being
thrown at me and I'm loving all of this
I do and she's a very smart smart woman
what do you think it because to me I
think that he really uh I think this is
a big problem for him because she seems
like she's not Donald yeah because she's
like you don't want somebody who's as
high-profile as she is you're not gonna
shut me up I agree with you and I love
how calculated this has been how
cautious she was with the first run of
PR that she did you know but she knew
this was the way this got all of the
info I hear but what's funny about Trump
people seem to forget everything he does
every day because there's so much going
on every day weirdly he's deflected this
so far yeah he hasn't addressed it once
we've all been talking about it he
hasn't addressed it once he addressed
the Academy Awards having low ratings
but he hasn't addressed this didn't he
address that it was not it was not mayor
did he say she was lying though I don't
think he said she wasn't noting this I
don't think in this run like in the in
this most recently like not that I've
seen anyone so you what do you think it
is she wants like if you had to guess
what would you say her endgame is what
like what would stop this for him and
what do you think she really wants I
don't think she wants anything from him
I think she's covering her tracks right
now because in a situation like this
even though supposedly the money went to
her Corp there's gonna be a tax
liability here and then also if you're
admitting that you accept hush money
then you were part of a bribe and you
were part of a bribing of in a grand
scheme of things so I think she's trying
to clear her name so she doesn't run the
risk for all these but if you don't
think Uncle Sam's not like right now up
have an extra Dunkin Donuts going let's
scrape this girl's taxes I mean I think
that's what Donald will do next is try
and find out how he can derail her but
this is the this is just crazy I mean
this if you really think the impact that
she should be having on America right
now people are walking around like
nothing's happened well can she can she
monetize this there has to be yes how so
she's already signed over she's gone
from wicked and now she's with Man 1
which is
brazzers pornhub these guys so she's
directing and shooting so she'll be
directing content she'll probably be
putting herself in a movie or two she's
on the road feature dancing just
crushing oh yeah yeah crushing crushing
it we were talking about before you got
here and you would be the perfect person
because you like when you did nailing
Palin you got to a whole nother level is
ever version of Sarah Palin yeah she's
my life like can you imagine if stormy
now comes out with the porn that people
want to see which is the trump when this
first and I reached out to stormy and we
had a beautiful conversation and I the
things that I want to address with her
is I know that she has a daughter and I
know that these things aren't easy when
they come this close to your home but it
also should motivate you more this is
life-changing money this is not just
making money this is life-changing money
I said just go get it go get it hard and
then you pick your family up and your
move somewhere and you just kind of tuck
yourself back in again but for now you
gotta get it take the money sure yeah
Penn Palin is similar with her I was 35
when I did Palin so I got it I looked at
it as an opportunity I knew I was gonna
get paid to go to other countries and do
events I did everything because you you
could you could did you they asked you
to dress like pale in and put the
glasses on I went to Finland is Palin I
did show up in the Greece I do dance and
play later I would dance as pillow
that's amazing then Eminem put me in his
music video for the song we made you as
paranoid so I got to come out as Palin
dancing to an Eminem video that I'm in
it's playing on like the things that
were happening to me were so next-level
cool I for once thought I was kind of
cool but you do normally I don't think
I'm cool at all like it's really a great
that was they did a great job with the
hair and I had no tattoos you know all
the things that they were looking
forward to finding a porn star today to
play a role like that right yeah rather
chesty in those photos yes I'm much
smaller now yeah I will yeah I will say
that I don't know if the sport jacket
fits properly not one that's too small
your breasts are hanging out all of
those suits myself I altered all of
those suits myself because I knew I
could never take them somewhere and say
I want this skirt this short I mean it
what kind of office worker am I so I I
do so and so I sewed all of my suits to
make them exactly
how I knew Larry Flint would like them
Larry Flint loves legs that's probably
his fever
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
okay because Jim is like the biggest
Larry Flint fan of all that was right on
the tip good I would say that Larry is
skewered so many people like how you
have to be able to I love you he's he's
bulletproof and not to like literally
like verbally you cannot offend Larry
Flint you can't where I moved here to LA
from Pennsylvania I was penpals with his
assistant to try and get myself into the
business and she's now his wife so it
really worked out for me when I got to
California I was already kind of in with
with them dinner with them and like
hanging out with them as this young girl
and I was just enthralled he's done more
for free speech and the focus on free
speech than any of these phonies like he
was literally shot for saying what he
wanted to say in parody what it was I
want to say was Cincinnati was worse
trial was yeah but he really he took a
boat for it and you know he should be
kind of hailed as a free speech hero
because he said so many unpopular rude
things that you should be allowed to say
great I wouldn't be able to do this as a
legal job if it wasn't for him I
wouldn't have had this opportunity think
about all of us working out there and
doing what we're doing because of him so
what do you think sorry you did the
Sarah Palin thing it did change your
life so you think stormy she just wants
to make money off this or does she what
do you think her end goal is I think
right now it's probably a little bit of
damage control this thing came out of
nowhere somebody found out about it she
was probably not planning on making
something this she was probably happy
with the 130 she's not buying handbags
right she's good with her money so I
think now she's going for a little
restitution right she's gonna try okay
how is this gonna pay me back I'll make
a little bit of money but what's
interesting is a couple of my friends
have had her at their clubs and they
were surprised it wasn't more crowded
and I said you know I think this is
different than Palin Palin was fun
because everyone found her entertaining
making fun of her was entertaining this
Trump world is very different and I
think some people are almost afraid like
look she still hasn't broken the half a
million mark on Twitter and she's been
trending on Twitter but I think people
are afraid to follow her because they're
afraid to be a part of this thing right
achill you're taking a side and so it's
working for and against her yeah maybe
it is I wonder if she's mad about the
130 though when you look at coverage of
billionaire and like you realize like
wow I am being talked about in the same
breath as the president it's different
than it was before he was president it's
just if she smart she can get that for
four or five scenes from browsers you
know I mean they got the money 30 it's
such an arbitrary number and I want the
one interview I want is the fly on the
wall swapmeet conversation that took two
weeks between her and whoever that I'm
sure she started at 250 right right and
they started at 50 I want to know how
you guys haggled 157 how about 147 going
once got you know what happened there
how do they get to 1/3 and is he gonna
pay her again like is there gonna be a
way to to shut her up at this point
right let me ask you this do you think
these papers can hold up being that they
used aliases in these contracts we had a
lawyer to sign it we asked about we
asked about that is there a paper like
is there that one connecting paper that
says she is this person she is Paul
Peter and he is dead is there a paper
that says that or is it both under oath
you'd have to testify and go no I'm not
that person and have to lie there might
not be something like that but then if a
lawyer sat you down I bet there has to
there might be or it might be go ahead
lie under oath because when I had all
those people write defamation statements
against me and I had to go to court when
I left the business they had defamation
claims against oh yeah where they
defamed you or they said you defame them
no against me they defamed me and one of
the girls wanted to use her stage name
and that was the only one I got thrown
out because I'm like listen if my name's
gonna be in the newspapers with this
real case we're not letting her get off
scot free with her stage name she has to
pony up and use her real name or nothing
and so they did throw it out cuz they're
like well she'll have to sign in in
court and this won't match the documents
so we're just gonna throw this one out
there all the people that like
because Lisa did I don't know if you
know Jim but Lisa had like there was a
army I went through years bullying my
family everyone in my life included my
home everything I had was disheveled I
had to go to court it was a very dark
time what was it like for what just very
hateful people in the business and I
think this business really wants to use
you before you use it I did crack a bad
joke that I didn't at the person on
social media but the person that I
cracked the joke about got highly
offended I did apologize and deleted the
joke but that started one full year of
my personal information being released
my family's information being released
harassing stalking death threats cops at
my house all the time was it a woman it
was a woman that started at yes okay and
you made great is many people that wrote
defamation statements or said horrible
things by Twitter I saved all of that
for court so I saved thousands of tweets
in my computer I saved all the
defamation statements now when they're
reaching out to me by Twitter I'm just
DMing them back like do you remember
this tweet no you will not be getting a
paycheck from my company is everybody
like oh yeah directors that wrote
defamation so I'm like didn't you
remember you said I used to steal things
from set and that's why no one wanted to
work three he's like oh well you know I
was just like yeah no you said I stole
things from set we will never work
together is it satisfying to be able to
send nasty tweets back to people they'd
sent them to you because you have to
remember in life which you put in
writing on the Internet is always there
and you have to think about what that
does to somebody and we've seen this now
we saw it with August Eames this past
December the girl that committed suicide
after being bullied on the internet we
have seen the impact this has you adding
in your two cents is not helping the
matter any you know this that I had
mixed feelings on network because it's
terrible to kill yourself but it's also
something that like you're predisposed
like Twitter can't make you do that even
though it's shitty what people were
doing and piling on she went out and
said something and like hey when you say
something people are gonna say [ __ ] back
to you and we hit the option with
Twitter's don't check the app mentions
when you're in your early 20s it's
harder yeah these kids that serve the
whole breadth of life and that's what
I'm trying to teach them coming back to
take one day a week a mental health day
where you
don't look at it at all you set up your
tweets the night before you let them go
out every hour on the hour and you take
a full day or you can even delete the
app from your phone put it back on later
but don't look at it yeah sometimes I'll
go through periods where I just don't
look at the app mentions because
something if I'm going through a pair of
people being dicks like I just instead
of just blocking a button and I stopped
checking it and then a week later it's
different it just goes away these young
girls remember all their validation now
comes from social media there's not
companies that are making them stars
they're not on box covers there's no
contract stars they're the the clubs are
hiring them off of their social media
numbers it's really a bizarre thing
that's taking place we've allowed it to
control them and so they're allowing it
to control themselves as well yeah
that's truly I fear someone in their
early 20s it matters a lot worse you
know I'm used to people [ __ ] thinking
I stink the career on that you do get a
thicker skin like it's not that you
don't care but like when message boards
and all that stuff first started being a
thing like in around 2000 and I would
starts it or whenever I noticed them I
mean a Bob Kelly's message board many
years ago mean Dane were going at it
under pseudonyms then we you know became
friends but like you realize early on
that people been you know how much you
can control it you understand what it
means and what it doesn't mean so even
though we'll annoy you it won't impact
you like all I got like if I was 21 it
would've been a different story of
course but it's so it's like it cuz if
you're gonna be public like there gonna
be people to think you suck like that I
think that's fine sure part of the deal
it's just people need to figure out how
to cope with the fact that the people
who think they suck have access to being
like now I can send it to you now I can
tell you because Twitter is on your
phone and you're checking it so it's
like I'm saying it to your face it took
me time to understand how to process the
information also to understand when to
look at it like I've told girls one
simple tip when you're leaving a dance
booking at four in the morning and going
to the airport just sit there till six
for your flight not a good time to look
at social media you're hungry you're
tired and you want to get home that's a
good time to read a book that's a good
time to learn something completely
change your focus and so those are the
little moments where if you're tired you
could read a tweet like I didn't even
mean to be mean you know you're blocking
I'm sorry
the next morning you're like whatever
that one for that was an O and not an A
oh geez is that a good or a bad feeling
when you're leaving the club at that
allegory a lot of times girls go right
to the airport yeah it's just easier who
wants to sleep for a couple of hours and
still to check out of the hotel you get
an early flight most likely it's not
delayed because the airlines like to be
on time first thing in the plane is
already there before so it's just easy
you know I loved it you'd be back home
by in LA by 9:30 10:00 you could sleep
all day at home yeah I do this I fly out
first day I'm just like one of us like
he's you know all this cash on you
you're going is it this I guess yeah cuz
the tips roll in cash that's one thing
and that business like a lot of show
business is not cash anymore it just
can't be but the tips the tip parts
deply cash and you know how much you can
carry with you and get through security
unless you have someone else with you so
you've got to always be thinking that
way as well I'll go to a Staples and
just buy out every single Visa gift card
they have like max all these out and let
me launder some of these money on these
Visa gift cards CDs more then I don't
have to have all this extra cash going
through the airport on right now but
it's still you know the week is cash you
can't protect it as far as losing it or
whatever yeah do you ever get scared
traveling with cash that's why I travel
with somebody yeah I do I mean you have
to think about it when the club wants to
put you in a horrible hotel to save $20
and like saved my life first
that I'd robbed the girl that I knew was
at the Red Roof Inn that just left your
club with $5,000 I'm there I mean yeah
the clubs do try to do that you it's
funny I'm gonna book myself some feature
gigs which I was not planning on doing
but then this happen right and then
clubs were like well you know we had
your host we we gave you this much and
we'll give you this much of dads I'm
like all order costumes right now and
some costumes some clear heels and we're
back but then the dance agents came out
of nowhere
and they've reached out to being one of
my than these guys are the worst
like no worse and so Frank calls he's
like so I want to know if you wanted me
to put your contract together I said no
you're standing in my phone right now
with your hand out like a cockroach I
already set these bookings up and you
think you're gonna email a contract and
get they want 15-20 percent they go he
comes back because we'll only take 10 I
said buddy you sucked when he wrapped me
before and you put me in Red Roof Inn no
yeah there you are
see we had an 18-month clause where if
you went back to a club within 18 months
you still had to pay the agent but I
haven't worked for them since 2014
wrinkle pounce and so down with you do
you get a hotel buyout a lot of times in
my gigs it's just a buyout like when
they don't give a [ __ ] where I sleep in
a car sleep where you want dummy here's
your money and then they'll play they'll
kind of pay for the hotel or if I get up
great if I want I like them to pay the
hotel and the travel in advance to me
that's their vested interest since I'm
not taking a deposit and so once they do
that I start advertising and I tell them
until I have the confirmation on the
paid hotel and the airfare we can't
change the name on the ticket once they
buy me the ticket it's my ticket so that
is what I look at as a deposit and then
I'll start promoting again okay so I get
okay and I'm not looking for a five-star
I'm just looking for like a Westin you
know i decent hotel that's clean that
maybe has a limited 24 hour room service
menu Westin fish I don't like a lesson
but you throw me in a Courtyard Marriott
and I'm a happy boy okay that's fine
gyms precious with his sheets and his
pillows love the sheets at the West End
it's they're too stiff he was just
really bad situations I don't like I'll
check out of West I won't stay in any
Starwood Hotels West End's I was just
I'll be leaning about the the hotel that
he stayed at last had king-size pillows
so he couldn't sleep because he likes a
smaller pillow yeah I'm a complete why
the front desk can you say I like kid
pillows like I'm sure you can that you
can ask for anything I do I ask for mid
of fire brought up in every room I'm at
and I put my essential oils in it and I
set up my room when Jim Norton calls the
front desk and says hey can I have some
child sized pillows for my room yeah the
authorities there's a guy asked my kid
pillows and rope three o'clock in the
morning duct tape and bleach so you'll
be in a hotel and a kid can be a little
bit scary so you travel with somebody
for security or chance we will use it a
boyfriend or a husband or just a friend
never that's so you don't want to deal
with that on the road you're still I
bring sand on the beach man you never
know what can happen on the road
you're not dating there's not MST dating
is not now stormy at Daniel's obviously
she said that her and Trump was just a
thing that she wasn't doing private
turning that stuff okay I believe her if
she says she wasn't she was I find it
hard to believe anyone would have sex
with him for free well I mean I'm not
drawn there I guess there's women that
are attracted I know you could also like
you said before for tax reasons too if a
guy's hand and get ten thousand in cash
it's kind of hard to declare that
Sheriff we would say that now could they
might say where's that money
I mean prostitution is illegal yeah
it is but in the case like this I don't
think they would go after her for that
they would more after the president but
at the same time and it's all up in the
air right now and if he forces the issue
for it to go after her like that it
could go down that way it is illegal if
she's got information in Texas you know
what I mean like this is this is there's
so many variables
there's also I'll you wonder if she has
texts from him I'm going to assume she
does they must have communicated via
text or I don't know about pictures but
there's she has pictures for sure
because that's that's what started this
they wanted to be sure she was gonna
scrub her social media of photos that
they had together
she had photos of him on her Instagram
four years from when they knew each
other so that's what you know in the
beginning of the presidency when they're
starting to scrub everything that's when
they started to reach out to people I'm
wondering how many more people he paid
off this way no but I mean photos not
just necessarily sex she's probably too
smart for that
that's not a bad photo let's see what it
looks like I'm super curious now I don't
wanna be near it alone but I want to see
a photo of it yeah of course I want to
see him you just inspired my thoughts
probably not that's a normal photo just
him and her that's not a damaging photo
cuz hey they're at a [ __ ] golf outing
I won't take photos with any famous
people I know I'm like you don't want a
photo with a pornstar it's just a bad
look and somebody's gonna make something
of it that it isn't so let's not do it
I don't do it yep I don't do it that's
crazy that's why she happily took a
photo with me she's like no not a
problem
no no problem have you had let me ask
you or have you signed NDA's in your
life no but I did make everyone sign one
my first shoot back since I wasn't sure
if I was gonna release it I'm like
everyone here has to sign this I'm
paying you all but I don't know if it's
happen yet so this is a dry run that no
one Wow idea is if you don't want to put
that scene out nobody ever knows that it
happens yeah so I made them all time so
you have it so when it just becomes a
home movie for you $9,000 day for a home
movie yeah you don't hear that much
about these people being outed like once
in a while but it's not that common it
seems like a lot of the girls are just
kind of quiet about it like I think more
girls are doing privates illegally than
ever and they don't want to out
themselves right you know that's really
what it is this wasn't a romantic do you
really think this was just a love
connection but he's also a very famous
guy what'd I say was maybe she didn't
pay or maybe it was through stuff like
flying her first class and a put her
five-star hotels got a good vibe jewelry
he's in tremendous shape yeah she would
probably not only want to give morale
second hold those hips the carpet match
the drapes these are all great questions
absolutely I want to know I'd love to
know his pubes look like he might shave
them and miss his hair like when a 71
guys change their beard annoys a giant
hunk still [ __ ] there you don't think
she gets down there does the work for
him no I don't think you would do
something I don't think she could be
near his [ __ ] with a razor without doing
real damage disgusting she's a cutter
I don't think Melania has been anywhere
near his crotch for quite some time
me neither ya know I bet you they [ __ ]
once an oil I don't think it's been
since the kid was born yeah I think it's
many years you think she's that maybe
she's not that committed to it I don't
know I think yeah I think just that
she's I mean I don't I just like I like
to hear the bombshell come out that
she's got some like twenty-year-old that
she's been hanging out with for two
years this would be invoiced really
spicy we talked about that before t he's
got too many people
he couldn't watch her there's no way for
her to do it cuz all he has to give
somebody 50,000 says find her doing side
come on have some cards oh okay
hey yeah the president didn't mind that
the guy who was writing his book was
[ __ ] his wife he didn't mind what I
gotta watch this a great show okay
it's a great show yeah I don't know
friend of mine did something recently
where he said that they were surveilling
escorts for some guy and
was like a teams that people on each
girl like the expenses were astronomical
because those girls don't even know
they're being watched
they have no idea and there was probably
six a team of six guys working at all
times cuz you had six different girls
I would totally know I was being watched
you know paranoid I am oh my god I would
notice that car behind me for a couple
of days I'd go out there in the middle
of the night like there's nothing about
you you've also lived it like so you're
not actually paranoid because these
things you're like oh I think this is
happening right it's almost all the time
it's happening you have a death-defying
stuff that happened now when something
really crazy happens I'm like ah you
know it takes so much more than that by
the way this question there's article in
the LA Times how much more humiliation
can milania traffic what I'm talking a
lot e of Trump is a [ __ ] ten she is a
extremely beautiful she seems like a
nice woman tonight she's a nice person I
met her once I don't you know obviously
know but she seemed she took it all in
stride at the first at Friars Club roast
in 2004 and she did like she is married
to the president of power but she can
marry a very powerful guy who are woman
hey that might be when I stopped dating
wouldn't that be crazy stupid I would
love it if Lisa and I ended up marrying
Melania interest she's so easygoing you
know I could cheat on her right right
right
Barriss her she has to be sick of this
because she's so beautiful she doesn't
need to put up with this [ __ ] but he may
convince her that all this is fake news
you know he may have her drink in the
juice what was the Michael Jackson was
the Jews happy friends hate them they're
all gay and foreign yeah [ __ ] friends
a prank like [ __ ] this guy I mean if you
watch her when he's giving speeches even
at the State of the Union like she just
looks not proud no no not even a little
bit I've seen parents at their
eight-year-olds basketball game that
look more enthused right and she's
saying there as the first lady where
she'll always looked proud I've had my
wife be proud of me for doing YouTube
know your wife's a wonderful
not just its it this is the one thing
that is keeping me watching the news
right now is for me Daniel story it's
amazing part this is gonna go down in
history I mean this is a big moment for
the u.s. well because there again we
talked to before like Clinton and we
talked about Marilyn Monroe and I think
all politicians they're most an 80% of
them are kind of like your [ __ ] other
women but this one is just being talked
about like and she's talking talking you
know and when I was working a lot of
these spearmint rhinos in LA I learned
about the judges and the politicians
there and they were the ones that came
in spend the most money to do the
strangest things like what what's it
really like to be peed on no they they
they were really like sexual deviant
would you pee on them where I didn't do
it but I would listen to the house girls
I I just learned I really just want to
address and there was a back room like
where on their body I don't know I
didn't ask for the private room like
what really is private like a wet room
remember the wet work but Jim would know
more about that thing yes my bed think
about it these are high-profile people
and usually they go that far over and
the other two get off right so they have
that deranged kind of thing that they
need and these girls knew it and these
guys had money the girls were quiet
about it they didn't say who they were
but I would just sit in the dressing
room and listen these girls cackle about
the dead judges and stuff they were
coming in like this is wild these are
the people who are making decisions in
our court cases in Los Angeles I feel
about this like they like some guy some
male escort just outed 80 priests or
whatever in Rome in Italy you know okay
they're all them are legislating and
preaching against gays and then
meanwhile they're [ __ ] paying this
guy and blowing them and there was some
really one of the one of the bigger guys
out of who's a cardinal or whatever he
was but he said he told to be do
something else for a living and that
because you you've been outspoken about
you don't like it the women that have
gone out and like blown up the
celebrities that have either DM them or
hooked up with them or whatever you
Khalifa does that right when you get to
a place where like you got this guy
who's outing them but it's like pure
hypocrisy right like there's actually a
message behind and in this situation
it's this is a pivotal moment this is
this is political you know
actually can create a movement instead
of some girl who didn't get the bribe
money that she wanted throwing an NBA
player under the bus and trying to ruin
his public image sure this is a movement
this this is gonna have purpose you know
this is huge so it's interesting did any
of your mainstream work get affected
when you started when you decided to get
back into porn I can swear on this
channel right absolutely so this is the
expression I'd like you to understand
that I understand my brain is not gonna
fall out of my vagina when I open my
legs right wait a min let me just
processed or I was a great statement
there was yeah and that's been my
response to people like people like are
you still gonna be allowed to do fantasy
sports and seriously and I'm like yeah
well luckily you know I my legs my
brains not gonna fall out of my vagina I
think I'd be just fine I just got to
keep studying and know my baseball stats
like nothing has changed so when I'm
walking this line where I'm showing the
world like what's wrong with you that
you think I'm different because I made a
choice that only affects you if you
choose to watch that's gonna be that's
gonna be the real difference maker if
you can it's one thing to leave porn and
going to the mainstream it's another
thing to be important and still have
this like in the mainstream you know I
mean that's what hasn't been what what
do you hate like you've done interviews
with a lot of radio people what is like
a hack thing radio people do what's your
favorite position what do you tell what
is it though guy if the guy has a curve
maybe your savored position isn't gonna
be your favorite position
hey Gerry speaking of curve that reminds
you see safaris dick Nicki Minaj's ex
wait this was like the base she was
trending and then she went off social
media and I heard it was a horrible
[ __ ] scene I didn't find out what
trying to did give a horrible [ __ ] on
a tape I know she didn't by the way was
it good she was I have been to like a
slow [ __ ]
I like a meandering okay a little
worshipping just a kind of like slow no
no I don't like the ones that are like
vomiting on you
my gag I can't take it when it happens
on set and people shoot that way I'm
just like it's so hard for me I look
I've always like I'm gonna throw up no I
like to have I like a nice teasing slot
like slow as soon icky Minaj's X okay
Safari a dick pic came out of him
dick how big a dick may imagine my own
video it's made fun of like people
thought it was corny it's just Nicki
Minaj's ex ba ba ba black Twitter turned
around entirely on him and he's now
become extraordinarily popular the
because of these photos him you know
what he put his best foot forward to be
exciting and there's a little curve and
you'd be great for shooting because we
need a guy with a curve because then he
can open up to the camera more than a
guy that doesn't have a curve so if you
know the curve then you look at the
location you say okay where do you use
the couch on this side because it curves
to the left and we're gonna get more
light in there because this guy has a
curve are there some guys you'll have
two scenes with that just don't go soft
regardless of what's happening there are
that's incredible as a guy phone rings
my dick is done for 40 minutes I don't
get it so it's like pushing rope up a
hill that's what I called it it's not in
my mind if it's not hard I'm like ah
Here I am again
hoping that I could push this rope up in
the hill to get my paycheck at the top
there it's humiliating but it's also I'm
in awe of the fact that anyone can keep
it a dick car with people watching and
like a unique gift and the director is
like let's go let's move give me a
little bit more I've watched them do it
and it's like that's why the music is
there its cover up the director y'all I
need better face come on give me a
little bit sadly though a lot of the
talent now is there's two things going
on in the business a lot of the guys are
spiking which is injecting oh yeah which
is something that I try to avoid because
I feel like that's open it's an open
incision right you you're drawing blood
at that moment which then you're at a
bigger risk and also when I did that
scene with China that went horribly
wrong and it hit a vein and when he
pulled out of her there was blood coming
out to the point where I'd never seen
anything like it I felt like I was in a
le coyote Acme Roadrunner like kind of
comic and this blood was just spurting
out everywhere and then and I remember
going that's why you've never worked
with anyone the injects I get it yeah
can we see yeah we can't find his uh the
video we of course they edited that part
out you're not gonna get to see the good
stuff so uh yeah I mean I guess there's
the pills I had in something other than
now I've heard there's something that's
that you actually insert other it is
that's him there you go oh good for you
and heard that one unsolicited Wow
what's your I thought is Lanie let's
cancel the rest of this PR tour let me
put my house up for sale and let me
offer him a contract with my company I
will shoot this boy as many times as he
wants to shoot but only MOLLE but his
penis is crooked that's fantastic for
opening up again we get the angles that
we need this guy has everything I need
you think he's making any money I think
no no yet I bet you I'm gonna stalk him
now you are this would be the contract
score of my life so you see money in
that flow in that video I don't even
know what it's there is a space whatever
it doesn't money money money that curve
that sighs those ABS that is I don't
have good ABS but not hurt me in the
business no because your face won't make
up for it oh very low but my favorite
moment would you is Lanie back that off
Mike I hope right now just through the
radio against the wall what why did I
not go down this rabbit hole on the
internet how do I not know about that it
took over social media for a good 36
hours when was this last week I must
have been listening to a Fantasy
Baseball Draft so this is but that right
now Safari has become your number one
potential signing Wow and I'll even let
him pick his own stage name I think
everyone that comes in the business
during a storm should have to use the
storms last name don't you think that
would be great yeah Quinn right now if
there's a girl that gets in the business
today her last name could be Quinn I
like that
would you allow Safari to use his music
as the soundtrack to the video
fantastic now we're really yeah that's
even better right his music is horrible
but whatever it doesn't matter
don't say that cuz you might hear this
yeah if he doesn't even know how to get
into serious I'm sure he only listens to
music on YouTube that generation they
use YouTube for everything they don't
know of any other formats no TV cable no
oh it's not on YouTube I don't know
about it but we're gonna put this out
there we're gonna try to let the world
know that Safari you've got a job yeah
at Lisa and Lisa and production lately
for you yeah and Lanie will do the PR
hang out - would you would you I would
most definitely co-star I think I should
be the first five or six scenes just to
get him comfortable being on camera
right right people around you I want to
just be good about practice in an
undisclosed location I don't know if I'd
invite him to my house know where I live
but on a hotel his penis is heavier than
mine I'm good for him yeah I always
wondered where his life was going and
now I know it's possibilities are
endless
yeah I know but I don't like his penis
is heavier than mine and bothers me it's
copy the whole thing always goes off
it's just like you know it's just go
ahead it's got more weight to it and
bothers me you find so yeah is that the
only thing it's different or just also
what about the width and the length
there might be a noticeable difference
if the most awesome male performer let's
say he's getting $1,000 a scene right
now he could easily get 2,000 2,500 a
scene with that unit 2500 bucks a scene
yeah